Rob here with a gs news update it has
been announced at Gamescom 2014 that
Metal Gear Solid Ground zeroes and the
phantom pain will be coming to the PC
tight shortly before the Metal Gear
Solid event today at Gamescom the Konami
website displayed a news article
claiming both games were coming to steam
during the livestream it was confirmed
by showing snake hiding in a cardboard
box printed with the Steam logo adorned
with a valve cue
there are currently pages in the steam
store for the games but no specific
release dates have been announced in
March Metal Gear Solid creators a day
Okajima expressed interest in a PC
release saying PC that's my original
background I originally created PC games
I cannot make a formal announcement but
that is definitely something that I
would like to do the Deo Kojima was also
involved in another big story at
Gamescom when an interactive demo for a
game called PT turned out to be a
playable teaser get it of a new Silent
Hill game that Kojima is working on in
some capacity with Guillermo del Toro we
spent almost 6 hours playing it
yesterday that game get a lot get to the
ground every bit that didn't hate it I
should hate that game it's pretty sick
in but if it sucks get anyways it's
great news that Metal Gear Solid is
gonna hit PC and we'll be sure to let
you know on GameSpot calm once we get
those release dates